David, do you think that the lunatic Trump
elected officials, that one in 20, 20,
like Marjorie Taylor Greene, Lauren, Bobert,
Madison, Cawthorn and others will be reelected
in twenty twenty two? This is a this is
like a chicken egg question. We wonder,
will Trump really run in twenty, twenty
four? We wonder, is the Republican Party
going in the direction of Trump or are
they going to reject Trump going forward?
That and this question of do Marjorie Taylor
Greene, Madison, Katherine and Lauren Bobert
become one term anomalies or anomalies, depending
on your preference, both pronunciations valid?
Or do they get reelected and ingrain these sort
of vapid Trump and candidates with no policy ideas
into Congress? The Tea Party in 2010, you'll
remember, essentially disappeared as a standalone
group. It's now a caucus within the House of
Representatives and many Tea Party ideas sort of
became integrated into the Republican Party, but
not as cartoonishly as they presented themselves
in 2010. Something similar could happen with Trump
ism, where some of these folks moderate and remain
in the party, or they all get crushed in twenty,
twenty two. And that signals a broader rejection
of Trump ism going forward. I think the reason
that at his speech at CPAC a week or two ago,
two weeks ago, three, two weeks, you know,
recently, I don't even know I don't even know
what year it is. Never mind when Trump spoke.
No. In the last month, Trump spoke at CPAC,
one of the reasons strategically that it made
sense for Trump not to announce a 20 24 run,
but to announce that he now is going to be
helping candidates in twenty twenty two to
donate to his PAC, so on and so forth.
Is that gauging his level of influence
through the elections of those he supports in
twenty twenty two will serve as a good signal
as to whether he should run in twenty
twenty four, whether he has a shot
in twenty twenty four. So I think the answer is
it remains to be seen. Trump's influence will
determine whether Cawthorn, Bobert and Green
get reelected. Green, Cawthorn and Bobert,
getting reelected or not, will signal the strength
of Trump ism going into twenty twenty four, which
will likely inform whether or not Donald
Trump runs. I still lean to Trump doesn't run.
My my thought is that to some degree, Trump
ism will fade over the next two to three years.
Trump will be nearly 80. And I see him
just kind of moving on to something else
or for other reasons. You know, health becomes
more of a question mark and Trump is not a
particularly healthy guy. My overall prediction
is if I had a bet today, I bet if you give me
even odds and I'm not a betting man, but if you
gave me even odds, I bet Trump doesn't run in
twenty, twenty four. Let me know your thoughts.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up right now at join Pakman dot com.